hello there Assassin's Creed Mirage is
here and I finished the game and would
like to share some of my thoughts with
you and some gameplay too no spoilers of
course Mirage takes the series back to
its earliest days with a focus on
parkour stealth and Mission planning to
infiltrate a stronghold eliminate a
Target and get out again unseen this
ends now
the 40-plus hour open world RPGs of
Valhalla Origins and Odyssey have been
replaced with the smaller location of
9th century Baghdad with an average play
time of around 15 to 20 hours
we play as bassim a returning character
from AC Valhalla who visited Norway
about 12 years after the events of this
game so Mirage is a prequel to Valhalla
what's noticeable right away is the
reduction of RPG elements the Litany of
choice such as weapons and shields has
gone bassim is designed to solely wield
a sword and Dagger exclusively and the
days of constantly checking which weapon
and which armor piece has the best stats
replaced instead by a much simpler
linear upgrade system
Mirage is much more like The Adventures
of Ezio and Altair with a few extra
flourishes for example as we grew up as
a street Thief we can pickpocket freely
and after 18 hours this is still my
favorite mechanic if you can spot a coin
purse it can be stolen and it's just a
single well-timed button press
incredibly satisfying this ability feeds
into a second mechanic as we can find
trinkets to sell keys to unlock doors
and sometimes the new currencies for the
game small favors that can be given to
Merchants for discounts or they can even
be offered as bribes to those
tight-lipped officials being light
fingered in AC Mirage is Thoroughly
rewarding though should we be seeing
pickpocketing or in fact any other crime
the notoriety bar grows in the lower
right corner we can hide and wait this
out or pay for the notoriety to be
reduced or do this the garden will be
ever Vigilant rip down wanted posters
until everyone forgets what you look
like these two mechanics alone make the
world feel a lot more rewarding to
explore
the mission log of typical Assassin's
Creed games has been replaced by the
investigation tab a constantly evolving
chart of suspects and potential leads to
follow I best blur this just in case the
beauty of this system is that the
smaller missions contribute to unlocking
a final assassination mission which in
turn makes story progression feel earned
rather than given and those final
missions close an investigation and
often reveal further suspects to start
another series of missions complete with
throwback to older AC games the dying
breath conversations it is our divine
will to rule over them right let's talk
about the combat in Assassin's Creed
Mirage because it isn't The Witcher 3
style we saw in Origins and it isn't the
more brutal style we saw of Conor in AC3
Mirage instead has decided to go all the
way back to the bare bone Basics Parry
Dodge and strike really simple
unblockable hits flash red to indicate
you need to move your ass the yellowy
golden flash represents a deflectable
strike that you and then our own hits
have two variations tap for a quick
strike and hold for a heavier attack I
honestly believe the basic nature of
this is to push Gamers to play the
stealthy way especially with the
Assassin's Focus ability to slow down
time and straight up Matrix a gang of
guards
stop
in a split second this ability feels
like a rechargeable get out of jail free
card I really struggled with the melee
combat for the first few hours and had
my ass handed to me many a time before I
understood how each enemy attacks this
isn't Dark Souls but once you get down
their attack patterns it's pretty easy
to annihilate an entire Squadron of
these guys like the heavy guards they're
too strong to battle face to face so
targeting their legs or getting around
the back of them is the way to get the
upper Edge it's only when these Elite
mercenaries arrive that things get so
tough you should think about running
away Pro tip remember to use your
surroundings whenever possible first
time but we do have more options to
choose from assassins tools Mirage has a
host of tools for bassim to use most are
designed for Stealth gameplay but using
them in fights is just as impactful we
slowly unlock throwing knives
noisemakers blow darts smoke bombs and
traps each which can be upgraded
separately for example using the noise
maker to attract foes over to an oil pot
and then throwing a knife in there to
trigger it boom or when overrun a simple
Throwdown of a smoke bomb can stop the
fight in its tracks and also give a
stealth takedown opportunity this is
where you'll find your only combat
variation a standard fight with sword
and Dagger are honestly quite lackluster
and when combined with that poor AI it
can feel quite basic but the flare on
the final hit always feels nice oh and
by the way there is a sword which adds
poison to your blade every fifth hit so
don't always stick to the sword with the
best stats there is a little bit of
wiggle room if you do a little reading
let's go on a typical set of missions in
mirage at least once per investigation
Basim is asked to track a suspect you
know the deal they walk slowly and turn
around every so often to check no one is
following them our job is to stay close
and out of sight using the parkour
system which has to be said is probably
the strongest it's ever been but yes
it's still clunky at times another
mission is to sit in cover and overhear
conversations for Clues literally
eavesdropping you are not telling me
exactly what it is we are missing those
are for information grabbing missions
then there are infiltration missions
which usually mean bassim needs to break
into a stronghold to take something or
rescue someone and it's always
jam-packed with guards and more often
than not one of them has a key to get
inside this type of mission can be a
complete bloodbath or a stealth master
class and it's totally up to you during
these scenarios your Eagle Vision is the
main tool by tapping left on the d-pad
Basin will see things all color
coordinated and easy to identify who
that's the key if all goes to plan a set
piece mission is granted with feather in
hand you'll use all the skills you've
learned up to that point to get into an
impossible location like this a palace a
thing that impressed me about these
final missions comes down to your Eagle
Eye in the Sky we can mark multiple ways
to approach this task for example it's
possible to slip past guards using many
methods one location has a crack in its
defenses perfect for Bassin to
physically slip in another has a crane
nearby which can be leapt from I entered
a mission through a water well once to
skip the wall and we can even pay a
contractor to get us inside as if we
were his workmate there are many ways to
get into these fortified missions some
easier than others and this always ends
with taking out your target to complete
the contract quietly with a hidden blade
or face to face Steel on steel hour has
come one thing I implore you to do
during your playthrough and that's
complete the side quests as they are a
mixed bag of small puzzles challenging
fights and Mission modifiers that
complete change how you approach each
task such as this combat mission where
taking damage is not allowed or
something I fail more often staying
unseen during a stealth Mission I can't
do that the collectibles on the other
hand can be locked inside buildings and
it's up to you to figure out how you're
going to get inside it could be throwing
a shuriken through a window to disengage
a lock it could be using one of those
oil pots to blow open a wall the side
content if I'm totally honest is better
than the story missions
I wanted to Circle background to the
story again after 16 hours I rolled
credits in Mirage I focused on the story
but I didn't Mainline it completely I'd
say I had about half the side content
done too so realistically this game will
take about 20 hours to platinum if
that's your jam but 16 hours to roll
credits and for about 10 of those 16
hours I totally stopped caring about the
narrative sold to us through this
investigation system it was boring and
there was no other word for it I was not
invested in the hidden ones hunt to find
the head of the snake and I found
everyone in the story back to
personality outside of a few very
specific examples I personally didn't
connect with anyone which may be a me
issue rather than a mirage issue I know
but then something happened in the
latter stages which I adored I won't
spoil anything but I have been pulled
back into The overarching Narrative of
the entire series after finishing this
game so much so that I plan to make a
timeline of events in Assassin's Creed
before I sum up you can't have an
Assassin's Creed game without a few bugs
I played an early version of the game so
these may be fixed in the final release
yet I still want to show you them I've
seen rats running across the sky NPCs
that cannot touch the ground others that
can be stuck in running animations there
are numerous bugged out takedown
animations and my favorite has to be
this floating dude in the middle of the
desert and an honorary shout out to this
funny walk all bugs I encountered were
only small ones nothing was game
breaking but it's fun to look at all the
same so the verdict Assassin's Creed
Mirage attempts to take the series back
to its stealth roots with a smaller more
refined World dedicated to establishing
the character of Basim simplifying
progression and removing RPG elements
will be jarring to many modern day fans
while all the fans will once again
recognize the AC series they fell in
love with in the first place sadly a
lackluster story partially rescued by
its final Act is not enough to make the
experience memorable with a few fresh
ideas on show the future of Assassin's
Creed looks promising but we're not
quite to that Promised Land just yet
that all said I do recommend Mirage it's
worth your time but definitely check
your expectations before beginning I'm
Adam you're awesome it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time